It’s fun to bash pale, stale, middle
class males for being entitled AF.
Especially when
they make it so easy.
But privilege is complicated.
It’s not just black and white.
Take the current batch
of Conservative MPs -
a bunch of white men so posh
they make Jeeves and Wooster
look like Kevin and Perry,
so privileged that
“the house of commons”
is how they describe literally
everyone else’s house.
But whoever you are,
if you’re watching this, it’s 100%
that you’re packing
some kind of privilege.
And just like a carry-on
containing oversize liquids,
you’ve got to check it.
Take me. On paper,
I’m a triple-threat minority -
a black queer woman
living in post-Brexit Britain.
I get to experience sexism,
mmm, racism, delicious,
or possibly the sexy blend
that is misogynoir.
Get you a bigot who can do both.
Plus, nobody really trusts bisexuals,
so I get straight up original
homophobia from straight people,
biphobia from the queer community,
and a whole lot of well-meaning
confusion from my mum.
Oh, my mum?
Did I mention that she’s
a first-generation immigrant
and that I come from
a single-parent family?
World’s tiniest violin solo.
OK, I’m not actually
going to shrug it off
and pretend that all
that stuff isn’t deep.
I’ve been assaulted,
abused in the street,
and had it assumed
by strangers straight off the bat
that I must love chicken
and twerking.
Which is awkward because…
Love a bit of jerk and twerk.
But, unlike a lot of people,
including some black queer women,
I have got a whole lot of privilege
going for me too.
I’m cis,
meaning my gender identity matches up
with the one I was assigned at birth,
neurotypical,
which means my brain basically
works the way doctors expect it to,
able-bodied, I speak English,
and through being born in London
I bagged a British passport,
which is basically a golden ticket to
gain entry to the rest of the globe.
A lot of why I’m doing OK today
is because I got lucky
in the lottery of life.
People are really good at seeing
other people’s privilege,
but tend to be pretty bad
at seeing their own.
It’s always my poshest friends
who say things like:
“Talking about money is so vulgar.
Let’s just all split the bill.”
I had tap water and a salad
for a reason, Florence.
I’ll split the bill when you
chip in to heat my house.
Also calling one quality a privilege
does kind of make it sound
like one end of the spectrum
is superior to the other.
You say black
like it’s a bad thing!
I love being black.
I love having lips. I love seasoning.
I love not being able to blush.
It makes me so
mysterious, so enigmatic.
Everyone’s asking: “What’s her
secret? What’s she hiding?
Maybe she’s born with it.
Maybe it’s melanin.”
We’ve got to stop using privilege
just as a stick to beat others with,
and start examining our own.
With great privilege,
comes great responsibility.